vsauce kevin here with the dumbest math
ever used to convict an innocent person
in a court of law it all started with a
little old lady in an alleyway and it
ended by defining how we use
probabilistic evidence in trials with
the california supreme court warning
that bad math could become a veritable
sorcerer to ruin law almost 60 years ago
a petty neighborhood robbery you've
never heard of changed everything
[Music]
an elderly woman named juanita brooks
was walking down an alleyway when
someone shoved her to the ground she
looked up to see a blonde woman running
away and that woman had taken juanita's
purse at the end of the alley a man
named john bass witnessed a white blonde
woman with a ponytail get into a yellow
car and drive past him he saw that the
driver was a black man with a beard and
a mustache these sound like the basic
facts of the case but they ended up
becoming numbers and it happened because
of total uncertainty john bass saw that
the woman had a ponytail juanita brooks
couldn't remember if she did a police
officer asked around local gas stations
until he found someone who said that an
interracial couple filled up their
yellow car there frequently janet
collins and her husband malcolm they'd
only been married for two weeks and now
they were being arrested for robbery
when juanita brooks and john bass were
asked to identify janet and malcolm from
photos neither one could do it juanita
completely blanked and bass only saw a
resemblance in the ponytail the police
still had some case their alibi was a
little shaky malcolm had a criminal
record and a recorded conversation with
police showed janet's desire to take the
blame to protect her husband and that's
when desperation kicked in the
prosecution turned juanita brooks
assault and theft
into a probability problem prosecutor
ray cinetar brought in a professor from
cal state long beach to help him prove
to the jury mathematically that janet
and malcolm collins were guilty the
professor testified to the validity of
the product rule which is that if events
are independent you can multiply the
probabilities of each to find the chance
that they happen together for example if
thing a has a 1 in 5 chance of happening
and thing b has a 1 in 10 chance of
happening then both of them happening
separately but together is one in 50 or
2 percent so what did cinetar do next he
started literally making up numbers i'll
explain in a second this video is
sponsored by bitdefender and their total
security they're a leader in the cyber
security industry delivering the
best-in-class threat detection
prevention and response solutions
worldwide bitdefender's total security
will protect important personal and
family data and devices from hackers it
works with windows mac os android and
ios it will not affect device
performance and includes a bunch of
tools to protect privacy such as webcam
protection and a microphone monitor
which you may want depending on what
you're doing on your devices they've won
independent awards such as pc mags
reader's choice and av comparatives
outstanding security product so to check
out bitdefender for an extended 120 day
free trial on five devices click the
link below that's an incredible deal you
basically get to try it out for free for
four months so thanks to bitdefender for
supporting vsauce2 okay cinetar invented
six vague estimates touching on the only
details that john bass and juanita
brooks could provide here's what he said
he said the chances of a black man
having a beard were one out of ten that
a man would have a mustache one out of
four that a white woman had blonde hair
one out of three that a woman had a
ponytail one out of ten that an
interracial couple would be in a car one
in one thousand and that a car would be
yellow one in ten
sure
the professor was given a pencil and
paper to work out the probability of
those six events happening together
using the product rule and he did the
answer was 1 in 12 million and that was
it he left the witness stand
yeah if you watched my video about sally
clark you know exactly what's happening
here the prosecutor explained to the
jury that this sort of mathematical
proof was actually better than the
concept of proof beyond a reasonable
doubt because it dealt with hard numbers
instead of vague beliefs he called it
the new math and he said it would help
convict the people who push old ladies
down and take their money he said that
malcolm and janet collins were the only
two people in los angeles who could
satisfy all the elements of probability
in this case he suggested that they had
to be the one in 12 million because with
all those pieces matching up how could
they not be but this wasn't new math it
was
bad math and it was still enough to
convict the collins's of second-degree
robbery and in jim crow era los angeles
there was almost certainly an element of
racial bias supporting it
malcolm collins appealed his conviction
and it went to california's supreme
court and they finally obliterated the
prosecutor's stupidity the math was
obviously wrong starting with the
completely made up odds of each
characteristic it's not like the
prosecutor analyzed the vehicle
registrations of all california
automobiles to determine that 10 percent
of the state's cars were yellow he
didn't conduct a massive survey of
hairdressers to find out what percentage
of their clients pulled their hair back
into a ponytail he just guessed then he
failed to acknowledge that these events
are not independent like beards and
mustaches you know they kinda tend to
come as a pair a lot not always but a
lot so you can't just straight up
multiply them like they're coin flips
but here's the big one
let's say the math is accurate which it
is you've found a couple who satisfy all
the conditions to be the one in 12
million great how do they know they are
the couple who committed the crime are
they the only two people in the greater
los angeles metropolitan area who were a
blonde ponytail and black mustached and
bearded couple in a yellow car surely
there weren't many but there's a decent
chance there's a few the supreme court
actually calculated the probability that
another couple fitting the same exact
description at over 40 percent
40 percent so even if the math checked
out there's pretty close to even odds
that janet and malcolm were the wrong
couple
three years later malcolm's conviction
was overturned and he was released janet
had been given a short sentence and
she'd already served it the collins's
never really got justice janet served
her time and malcolm lost a few years of
his life but the biggest loser was the
validity of probabilistic evidence it's
the most glaring example of the
prosecutor's fallacy and it's taken
decades to undo the damage rey cinetar
caused to the use of math in the
courtroom but the fallout wasn't all bad
it did lead to the collins test a set of
conditions the introduction of
probability needs to satisfy for the
math to be relevant and valid in a trial
one the probability factors need to be
accurate you can't just make them up
two the calculations are done correctly
and formulas are applied appropriately
like not abusing the product rule to get
the result you want
three all the factors being calculated
actually apply to the parties involved
four and the evidence proves there could
be only one result so that the collins's
could be the only possible couple
capable of satisfying every condition
the police never did figure out who
knocked juanita brooks down and stole
her purse
in 1965
two criminals in los angeles got 40
richer and math got a lot less
trustworthy in the courtroom but without
it we don't have the collins test or an
ever evolving debate about how we can
leverage what we know about math to find
out what we don't know
about everything else
proving that
sometimes things have to get
really dumb
before we can even start
to get smart
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you